I'm James Powell you can tweet at me at
don't use this code if you like this
presentation or if you have any
questions about what I'm about to
present I want to give you a disclaimer
usually I don't know if any of you have
seen any talks I've given before this is
I think the 26th or 27th now maybe
thirty fourth or so PI data I presented
at given a lot of PI data talks usually
they're complete nonsense something fun
but very silly this talk as you can see
from the title is intended to be useful
and I thought that I wouldn't be able to
convey to you through the material in
the talk please don't use this code so
instead I decided to grow an absolutely
absurd mustache because nobody can take
this seriously with this thing in place
so that's my disclaimer let's get
started so this talk is about a very
simple scenario that I think we've all
encountered at some point in our working
career we're working somewhere one of
our colleagues left they left us with
some large code base maybe 50,000 lines
of code and now it's your problem to
deal with what they left behind and what
I want to go through in this talk is a
simple guide for what you do when you're
put into that situation on this is a
very complex and very deep topic and in
the span of 45 minutes I don't know that
I can give you all that you need to know
about it but I wanted to touch upon a
couple of common points because it's
something that I faced all the time in
my work and I wanted to give this to you
as a mixture of a couple of simple
techniques and a little bit of
theorizing around the topic to try to
understand how can we break down a
problem that immense and so we'll do
this very basically step one find a new
job there is no step two thank you for
much anybody have any questions okay so
I heard a bunch of questions in there
let me see if I can answer some of them
one of them is why lines of code I mean
it's a very imperfect metric but I think
it's a very understandable metric it
really doesn't you know when we say
fifty thousand lines of code what we're
referring to is a very specific thing
it's not five million lines of code it's
not five lines of code it's something
that's a sizable problem that you might
expect would be within your capability
to pick up but in practice turns out to
be very difficult and in fact I think I
heard somebody say actually this is more
a comment than a question but doesn't
really depend what fifty thousand lines
of code we're dealing with a colleague
of mine told me when when we were
discussing this talk that they had
written a hundred thousand lines of code
in a month that's ridiculous I mean
that's enormous productivity I think the
industry average that people have been
talking about since the 70s is average
programmer writes about a hundred lines
of code a day and if you think there's
about two hundred working days in the
year that means that the average
programmer outputs to twenty thousand
lines of code and this statistic albeit
a very flawed statistic is a Sicily
that's used to promote languages like
Python because the thought is would you
rather write 20,000 lines of Python in
one year or 20,000 lines of C in one
year
but what you can think is obviously it
does depend on what the 50,000 lines of
code are if for example you're given a
50,000 line code base and you run c-loc
on it and it shows that it's 20,000
lines of HTML and 20,000 lines have
react and 10,000 lines of Python that's
a very different problem to solve then
if it's 50,000 lines of pure Python
obviously some type of code like HTML
you have other techniques to refactor
that but since it's not active code
there's a certain limit to the
complexity that an individual line of
HTML can contain it's a lot easier to
deal with so for the purposes of the
further questions that we'll be
answering for the remaining 42 minutes
that we have in this talk let's just
talk about Python we'll talk about the
kind of code bases that we interact with
day to day which are large Python code
bases usually what you might call an
application or a system as opposed to a
core library now for some of the
analyses that I'll talk about in the
further questions that I will be
answering will I ran some of these on
some code bases that I've used for work
and some common libraries like
matplotlib that we used depending on
what kind of code base it is whether
it's application code system code
whether it's a library code some of the
metrics that we look at and some of the
techniques that we look at will or will
not work now one really interesting
question that I did here on the cab ride
over here this morning when somebody
asked me why don't you use a machine
learning algorithm to try to understand
the code that you have and I thought
that was a very interest
thing topic I think that the topic of
using some of the rich data analytical
tools that we have in order to
understand the code that we're producing
is something that doesn't really get a
lot of coverage I think one of the
reasons for that is if you think about
it when you're writing code you're
essentially modeling and irreducible
complexity the the unending profundity
of the real world into a semi
mathematical model typically when you're
using a machine learning model you're
dealing with a much more concrete
mathematical entity it turns out that
machine learning models can give us some
very interesting results where those
mathematical entities correlate very
closely to real-world tangible things we
can think of like image recognition you
know the pixel value can somehow
correlate to recognizing an entity or
not but if you think about it it would
be very difficult to thoroughly
mathematize the functionality and the
requirements and the complexity of a
code base in such a way that you could
feed it into a machine learning model
and get something out of it although it
would be an interesting exercise to try
and if somebody wants to tweet at me
after I don't know uploading a code base
into a machine learning model and trying
to predict what the next line of code
would be that would be very interesting
if you could figure out a way to
actually structure that problem now one
question that I think I heard among all
of the questions was this is actually
happening and I think is happening to me
a number of times every time I just
found out a new project or a new job in
a couple of cases I wasn't able to do
that and so I've had to deal with it but
if you think about it if somebody sends
you an email and they send you five
lines of code you just use those five
lines of code there's really a generally
incompressible amount of complexity that
you could see in five lines of code
maybe you could refactor those five
lines of code into one library call
maybe you could fix the syntax a little
bit maybe there's a corner case and so
those five lines of code turn it to
seven or ten lines of code but that the
five line of code number is really not
that much that you have to deal with in
fact you can read through it either
decide to use it decide to refactor
all in the span of about an hour if
somebody gave you 50 lines of code or an
email saying hey we want you to use
these 50 lines of code you could
probably just rewrite that code you
might not even read through it you might
just ask what does this do and in the
span of about a day you could probably
just rewrite it from scratch and ignore
what you were provided another question
that I think I heard was what's the big
deal I mean
two thousand lines of code really but if
we continue that thought process if we
think about five hundred lines of code
what happens when somebody gives you
five hundred lines of code well that
might have some hidden complexity it
might have some hidden state it might
require access to some resources like a
database in my a very complex runtime
context and so most likely what you
would do is you'd read through it you'd
rewrite it and the entire time would
take about a week and you begin to see
that there's an interesting expansion of
effort because in a very productive day
almost certainly all of you in this room
have written two hundred three hundred
four hundred five lines of code but I
would I would doubt that in a very
productive day would be very easy for
you to rewrite that in just just a
single day so you can see what took you
maybe one or two days to write may end
up taking somebody else one week to
rewrite one week to refactor one week to
understand now if we extend that further
for 5,000 5,000 lines of code that
becomes maybe a month long process where
you'd have to read through every line
maybe try to understand what's going on
in that code maybe write some tests
around it and I think the 5,000 line of
code target is about what you see when
people give talks about refactoring via
test-driven development typically
they're talking about small libraries
where you can easily identify what the
functionality is where the complexity
generally is and write a couple of tests
around it and over the course of a week
or two start to dismantle that
complexity and understand what's going
on
I think another common question that
comes up is why not ask for help with
this and if you think about it if you
were given five hundred thousand lines
of code or five million lines of code it
is very unlikely that a single person
has written 500 thousand lines of code
or five million lines of code and
honestly if you're given five millions
of lines of code written by one person
not only should you quit your job but
you should quit your job
sort the stock of that company and run
as far away as possible
convince your friends to quit your to
quit that job or alternatively start a
consulting company just sit wait around
until the company comes to you because
they're hopelessly there just in a
hopeless situation having to deal with
five hundred thousand lines or five
million lines of code written by
somebody maybe hire the original author
who wrote this and cash in but generally
what
see four large code bases like that is
it's the work product of multiple people
and so there's usually some form of
documentation there's either a mailing
list there's either a SharePoint site
there's either a wiki there may be in
encode documentation in the form of
comments there may be some remaining
artifacts of the development process the
problem is oh let's see if we can get
back to where we were the problem is
when we oh that's a nasty live editing
our slides right there we go the problem
is when we deal with something in the
middle this this five five 50,000 line
of code level because when you're
dealing with 50,000 line of code it's
possible that it's the work product of a
single person done over the course of
maybe one to three years if you think
about that metric 100 lines of code per
day that's about 2 to the 3 years worth
of work that somebody could have done
because it's the work product of a
single person doesn't necessarily mean
that it's not completely critical to the
operation of the business unit or the
company itself but it does mean that
that person could have encoded a number
of hidden requirements into this code it
means that there could be a lot of hot
spots where there's some small corner
case in the business model that's being
addressed and it's entirely possible
that there are no documentation and
there's no tests whatsoever in that code
base because since it was a work product
of a single person they could keep all
of the work in their mind and they
didn't need documentation they didn't
need tests they just kind of knew how
the thing worked and the most cynical
and unfortunate part of it is they may
have set unreasonable expectations
because think about it the work product
of one person that's 550 thousand lines
of code they could have turned around
code fixes or new features in the span
of maybe a week or a couple of weeks
when you inherit this codebase this is
now beyond what you can read through in
the course of a week or a month
it may take you as much as a year to
actually read through and understand all
the complexity in that code but when
that gets handed over to you it from a
business perspective you go from
somebody who was able to turn around a
feature request or a bug fix and
anywhere between a couple days to
- now somebody who has to say well I
can't do any work on this system until I
have spent a couple of months to read
through and rewrite it and so you have
to be incredibly strategic in order to
manage these expectations if you're not
then you're suddenly seeing enormous
degradation in the business process
because you can't respond as effectively
as the original author and yet you have
none of the resources none of the tools
none of the built-in knowledge that
original author had and so I think the
only other reasonable question is we
know that if we're put into the
situation we should find a new job but
even in as good a job market as we're in
you may not be able to find a job that
quickly and so what do you want to do
while your table searching well if you
don't mind just getting fired I would
say take your vacation time or just kind
of send a couple of emails or just slag
off the old author as much as you can
but if you feel a little bit of
obligation to your former company and
you actually want to do something that
maybe helps them before you book it and
you get out the door there's maybe a
couple of things that you can do and I
would say that if you were to think
about this process one of the main
things you want to do is you want to fix
your expectations the original author
was able to work within this very
degraded software development lifecycle
this very degraded soft development
process where there might not be
documentation there I might not be test
but they're still able to be effective
and they set a set of expectations that
you will not be able to meet and so one
of the most basic things that you want
to do to set those expectations is just
find something to run and run it this is
absolutely critical if you cannot run
the code there's very little that you're
gonna be able to do other than slag off
the old author and update your resume
and one of the unfortunate things is I
have been given code bases where I could
not run them to say or just run the test
suite there may not be a test suite I'll
just run a sample app there may not even
be one I've been in situations where the
code runs on a remote machine that has
access to specific databases or specific
resources and I can't just sit at my
console and import a module and run it
and so the absolute most critical thing
to do is find some runnable context in
which this thing works in which this
thing runs from completion or if it's a
long-running tool run you know you can
start it up be
cuz once you're able to run it you can
then begin to try to dismantle its
complexity unfortunately Python is such
a dynamic language that you're going to
be you're gonna find it very difficult
to understand a Python code base unless
you apply dynamic instrumentation and
dynamic analysis techniques especially
in the hotspots in the code where
something kind of hinky is going and
those are the hotspots which you might
be able you might be obligated to fix a
bug or to extend functionality one of
the things that I also try to do is I
try to iteratively narrow my focus as
much as possible when I first was given
an assignment like this when I was very
junior at one of my first jobs my goal
was to thoroughly understand the code
base and to be able to confidently say
everything about how it worked and
within a week of no reportable progress
I realize that's not going to work at
all in this degraded scenario of you
being given a lot of code with no
support you need to kind of disabuse
yourself of the notion that you're going
to have mastery over this codebase and
you need to try to find as narrow a
portion of this code base that you can
do something with as possible you may
never be able to understand the entirety
of it but there are a couple of general
rules of hand that I've seen with
regards to these kind of code bases most
production code bases especially when
you're talking about an application and
not a library most of the time less than
20% of that code is interesting most of
it is just application of some core
library or some technique to some
business problem and 80% of its just
application of the business problem and
you don't really need to touch that and
generally most of these code bases about
50% or more of it works and so there is
some core of that code base that's both
interesting and either needs new
features or is buggy and needs to be
fixed the problem is how do you find
that and what I found often is if you
want to kind of break it down in a large
code base like this there's some portion
of that code that you might say is dumb
code it's boring code there's some
portion that's smart code or interesting
code the boring code is code that is
generally very static it's very
repetitive it's typically applications
of some core tools or libraries and
there tends to be a lot of it
when I say static what I mean is we know
Python is an incredibly dynamic language
we know we can do monkey patching we
know we can have first-class functions
we can we do all sorts of things that
make it very difficult to statically
analyze our code which is why tools like
my PI or pet 484 type type in ting have
limits to what they can provide to us
similarly it's it's relatively difficult
to make generalized refactoring tools in
Python like the Java community uses all
the time typically the majority of the
code base is static it's boring it's
just people calling static calling
functions where we know lexically what
that function is where you can trace
that function back to the import and
there really isn't this dynamic dispatch
or this indirection that you'd expect
from the interesting code the smart code
or the interesting code the minority of
this code base and very likely the place
where you need to dig in and do
something tends to be very dynamic so
there might be some code which is using
configuration in order to generate what
functions get called that dispatch may
not be determinable statically you may
need a runtime context to even figure
out where the code goes for example if
you look at how set up PI and dist utils
work try to figure out what the process
is from going to the from the entry
point of a set up py to the actual code
that runs or if you look at a tool like
clique or any of these other command
line generators I actually try to figure
out how much code runs between you
passing in a single argument to
determine what command gets run and the
underlying function similarly for web
framework like flask or Django just try
to as an exercise try to see how far
there is between when the the web app
actually receives an HTTP request and
when it actually is able to dispatch
that to a view function or a view class
is that there tends to be a lot of code
in between there and there are many
decisions that can be made that can
guide the direction of that code
differently this smart code often tends
to be very core to the to the operation
of the library it tends to be fairly
minimal in terms of where it is and it
also has a tendency to be very scattered
throughout the codebase so it may not be
easy to find that code sometimes I've
seen code bases and I struggle to even
figure out where the meat is
it's all bread or all you know pasta but
the
bits of meat inside are very difficult
to find and so one of the things that I
find that's necessary is trying to
figure out how to find that
now there's another core dichotomy that
I've seen which is it's very difficult
for us to analyze smart code statically
it's just too complex
there's too much dispatch there's too
much knowledge there too many there's
too much states going on at the same
time and we often cannot analyze dumb
code statically because there's just too
much of it in in terms of the lines of
code there is we can't read through it
we might be able to apply some static
techniques but we won't see anything
that interesting and the interesting
patterns that we'd see there are not
particularly visible and unfortunately
try and distinguish where the dumb code
and where the smart code is is also very
difficult I would encourage you to take
a library like matplotlib or numpy if
you've never looked at those libraries
before and actually try to find out
where the ndra is defined that's the
core of map of numpy I actually try to
find out a matplotlib where the draw a
graph is generator and how that's
processed and that's also very difficult
to find in the depth of all of the other
functionality that wraps you know these
core data models now when I say you need
to find something to run it obviously if
there's a test suite run it I'm part of
the reason to run a test suite is not to
have that foothold into runnable code
but also to set your expectations
because there is no guarantee for the
work product of a single person that the
test suite actually works I've seen test
Suites where the author didn't need to
run the test suite all the time so half
the tests fail because they haven't been
updated it was just too much effort for
them to do I imagine for your own work
product where you're not sharing this
code with anybody else or we don't
expect to share this code anybody else
how often do you really write and
maintain and pay a lot of attention to
your tests especially if your actioning
requests for additional functionality at
a fairly pass fast rate but you can set
expectations by at least telling your
boss look I can't do anything with this
code base test suite doesn't even run
ideally there's some sample code
somewhere and just being able to run
even a dumb sample app is useful ideally
there's also some production code that
you can run and you can see in its
operation if it's a if it's more of a
system or an application than a library
the idea here is you want to set a base
not only in terms of the expectations
that you're broadcasting to whoever
you're responsible to for the
maintenance of that code but also to set
a baseline for the requirements for what
the code takes to run because it's very
often the case that you may not find
that you can just run this code in a doc
obtain in a virtual lab you may need
some very complex set of environment
environmental variables access to
database resources it may not be able to
be isolated or a very good goal once you
have a foothold in this code base and
you're more comfortable once you've been
able to get it run in any fashion
whatsoever is to try to reduce the
runtime complexity of the the context in
which it runs try to isolate the code as
much as possible because if you get the
code to run in a doc container with no
access to any other folders without
network access with only a list of
enumerated requirements code library
requirements then it's gonna be a lot
easier for you to start to tease apart
that complexity a lot of very complex
code bases end up being complex because
they're reliant on state that's relying
on things that are not tracked in the
code itself in the requirements txt or
the requirements nor the set up top py
additionally that runtime context is
very important because the only
effective way that you can really
understand what's going to go what's
going on on a large Python code base is
via dynamic analysis and unless you have
a runtime context to throw your dynamic
instrumentation tools into you're not
gonna be able to get anywhere so one big
thing is what if the software is data
driven been given large code bases what
are which are drive driven the actual
code base itself relies on some data in
order to determine the modalities in the
code base you're out of luck here
because a very data-driven app but
written by a single person unless you
have a sample set of data that exposes
all the possible modalities of that code
base you're gonna have a lot of
difficulty really managing that code
base because you're not going to know
there's going to be functionality that
you won't be able to ascertain actually
exists until you see the sample data
this is the case where I've seen cases
where you have an application that
relies on an object database so people
are storing Python objects and some you
know no SQL object database those Python
objects are pickled so they have
functionality
associated with them the application
might load a bunch of objects like
imagine if it's a finance a trading
application and it has a portfolio and
each object represents a single position
in that portfolio and each object has a
price method well unless you know what a
sample portfolio looks like you don't
know what the price methods look like
you don't know what the price method
looks like you have no idea what the
actual extent of what that code can
actually do is and you'll never be able
to really get a hold on what's happening
so a really important question is how do
you find the smart part of the code
because you're given this enormous code
base you cannot read through 50,000
lines of code in a week unless it
happens to be exclusively dumb code and
the monotony of reading through 50,000
lines of code makes it very easy for you
to skip over the interesting or the
smart parts that just have your eyes
roll to the back of your head and to
just kind of zone out while you're
reading through it so a very important
thing is how do you find the smart part
and another important question is why is
it important to analyze this code base
dynamically why is it difficult to
analyze it statically so to start with
let's think about some very simple
static analysis techniques when I was
coming together with when I was putting
this talk together I asked a couple of
my colleagues who are core developers at
different Python libraries some of the
techniques or tools that I've used and I
asked them for some of the static
techniques they've use and some of the
dynamic techniques they've used a very
simple static technique is what we saw
before just runs c-loc to figure out
what what what languages are used in
this code base how much of this is
Python how much of this is C if you run
that on something like matplotlib you'll
see there's portions of that code that
aren't fortran there's portions of that
code that are in c for the most part if
you were inaugurated as the BD FL of
matplotlib it may be the case of that C
code or that Fortran code is so old has
been around for so long you probably
don't have to look at it immediately you
may only eventually have to look at it
you might want to focus your attention
on the parts that are more user facing
which would be the Python code similarly
if you see a code base and there's a lot
of HTML or CSS you can narrow yourself
and start to whittle down how much of
that code you actually care about
another approach would be you know one
person said just take all the code print
it out and just sort it by the lines and
you may begin to see certain patterns if
you look at a single line and just sort
by what's the most common line I ran
this on matplotlib the most common line
was
an empty line then there was actually a
couple of documentation lines that were
very common doesn't give you a whole lot
of information for a library but imagine
you have an application where certain
function calls are called over and over
again or maybe it's a library where you
have users who are writing little
scripts or plugins for that you'll start
to see common lines like database access
like setting up the context and you'll
begin to see a couple of hints about
what the general pattern is it's not
that useful of a tool unless the code
base is written in a very repetitive
fashion another approach might be you
know just take every every file split it
onwards and find the most common words
because you can think if the code base
is written very statically and there's a
bunch of function calls and it's always
just from module import function a and
there's a bunch of lines that say call
function a call function a call function
a you can at least find what are
commonly called functions again in
library type code this is not that
useful because if you think about the
way that that code would be written if
people were repeatedly calling the same
set of functions in the same order
somebody's going to add an abstraction
where that's extracted out in order to
minimize the amount of repetition we're
told as programmers don't repeat
yourself and we're told that this
normalization of our code makes it
easier to maintain and so the desire to
normalize our code and to not repeat
ourselves ends up defying our ability to
analyze it statically now we can improve
the static analysis better by you know
doing things like using pythons
tokenized module to actually tokenize
the code if you do that you need to do
something a little bit more
sophisticated have to remove keywords or
remove punctuation and if you do that
you can at least find certain general
themes of the code base like for example
what variable names are used often when
I read this on matplotlib I found a
couple of variable names referring to
you know our C params comes up as one of
the most common tokens and matplotlib
and for those of us who are matplotlib
users we can kind of understand why that
would be does it give us that much
insight into the code no but it gives us
a little bit of a foothold cause on the
boss-ass so it's been one week where are
you you can say well I know our C
programs is really interesting I don't
know how useful that will be but it
gives you a little bit of a foothold as
to trying to understand what's important
or what's common ideally if this code
base is very static that might you might
see in the most
most of that common function names or
common module names percolate to the top
but you might have to do a lot more
filtering and if you think about the
output of this if you look at the first
200 items it might take you an hour but
you might it might give you something
that's worth grabbing for so these
static unfortunately where we're guided
as programmers is to defy the ability to
statically analyze our code so we need
to have some techniques in order to
dynamically analyze our code and this
tends to be much harder to do in Python
that it is to do in Java or C I want to
go through just a couple of simple
techniques that I've used in order to
static in order to dynamically analyze
code now first we can talk about these
is what you might call instrumentation
mechanisms mechanisms which takes some
code and add a little bit of information
you have some context which you can run
this code either sample code a test
suite or a production code in many cases
if the production code is doing a lot
like it's some kind of high-frequency
mechanism that's responding to requests
very quickly the amount of output that
you generate from these instrumentation
mechanisms may not be understandable by
human being so you might have to take
that output and then apply both data
analysis techniques to it like
generating histograms what's the most
common output or writing analysis tools
to actually analyze the output of your
instrumentation that is not that
uncommon but let's assume at least for
the purposes of looking through these
instrumentation mechanisms that the
output of these are within what you can
look at in an afternoon and understand
as a human being without applying
another metal layer of instrumentation
analysis a very simple thing that people
might do is you might start with very
holistic instrumentation like you could
use a tool like s trace and try to find
what are all the files that are opened
what are all the files that are touched
read written to by by your tool that at
least gives you an ability to try to
understand what the runtime context is
what configuration files does this look
at what you know there's a database or a
socket that's opened what what's touched
by this file what modules are touched by
this file where those modules are
located it's often the case that if this
is not been deployed correctly it may be
that the modules that are used by this
are not isolated into a condo
environment or a virtual environment but
they may be scattered wrong the file
system and you may end up looking at one
version of a library that you think is
being used and being misled because it's
actually stored somewhere else so this
at least tell you generally where all
the files of this thing reads how useful
is that well it gives you at least one
baseline to figure out what the runtime
context is if you want to figure out
what the runtime context is another
thing that I see in complex code bases
is they'll make use of environmental
variables those environmental variables
will determine how the thing runs they
won't just be things that are passed
into the on the command line and so you
can always go into the OS module and
just patch out OS not environ and you
could see what environmental variables
are actually being looked at think about
a code base that that you've run where
it has like a UAT a QA and a production
environment there may be environmental
variables that cause modalities in that
code base that cause you to follow one
code path or another unless you can
actually figure out what the
environmental variables that are
actually looked at you'll never be able
to parse down your not be able to pare
down the the runtime context for many of
these apps it's like a shell script that
set some environments or variables that
calls another shell script that calls
and other shell scripts that finally
calls a Python system if you can at
least track at the end what those
environmental variables are you might be
able to start paring down the execution
context so you can I eventually isolated
into a docker container so you can have
some fixed boundary around what this
thing does or what this thing touches it
was that you know another dynamic
approach you might use Python is
actually full of dynamic analysis
techniques and tools for that so another
approach Python and the Syst module has
a line tracer you can do a set trace one
thing that I've done is you do a set
trace you run your test suite you you
create a histogram of every filename and
every line number that's touched think
about this the static analysis technique
where you do a sorting on the lines of
code that you see or you do a tokenizing
and a histogram on the tokenizing that's
gonna mislead you because if somebody
has refactored that code suddenly
something that's touched a hundred times
has now only touched five times because
there's now some layer of abstraction
that reduces the repetition however in a
runtime context that repetition still
exists and so if you look at every line
of code that's executed as part of the
execution of your test suite you might
actually able to find out where the
hotspots are you can see oh when I run
my test suite of a thousand lines of
code you know this one particular line
of code in this one particular module
gets called fifty thousand times
so that's probably
close to where the interesting part of
that code is or you can start to graph
out more or less what modules are
interesting what files are interesting
and what lines are interesting you could
do the same thing it just looking at the
file name or just looking the package or
the module if you do this for so I did
this for Matt plot live with a very
simple pie plot histogram to try and see
what that would give me and I was able
to pick out certain parts of matplotlib
that I didn't know we're that
interesting where those lines of code
were being executed 10,000 times for
actually not 10,000 lines but like 50 or
60 times for just a simple execution of
a simple graph now the information that
I was able to glean from that did not
give me more information to understand
how Matt palatable work but if I ran it
over the entire test suite I might see
certain certain areas like you know
general configuration dispatchers which
every piece of code goes through and
those will start to percolate towards
the top and it'll give me a little bit
more of an indication of where I need to
start looking by the way we haven't even
gotten to maintaining it we're still
trying to figure out where to look this
is what happens when you're put into
this situation you don't even know where
to start
now another technique that I have
employed successfully is you know in
Python you have system meta paths where
you can insert into Python hooks that
hook into the import mechanism what I've
done before is I've used Network X and a
custom meta in port hook in order to
what the import up does very simple
every time Python tries to import a
module my import hook says yeah I can
import it internal to that import hook
it just reinforce the importing
mechanism and it keeps track of what
imported what importer what this
actually works surprisingly well in
Python because the importing mechanism
of Python has a lock around it so it's
impossible for multi-threaded code to
actually to actually call this thing in
parallel and so you have you can write
some fairly simple it's about 20 lines
of code fairly simple mechanisms that
assume everything is single threaded
irrespective of how the application
actually runs that constructs a graph of
this module imports this module imports
this module import this module when I
did that I began to see in that
application one module that everything
imported and that was a place where I
wanted to start looking because if you
think about it application code it's
often the case that if it's written well
there's some
core and it's a hub-and-spoke model
where some core is used by everybody and
then everything's kind of a spoke off of
it
however if you do that and you see a
spiderweb where there's no one place
where everybody convenes then you really
know you better hurry up in your job
search because this is gonna be a real
mess and it's not unusual for codebases
to end up with that pathological case of
this it's no longer a hub-and-spoke with
just a web where everything imports
everything and it's difficult to
identify what the core part of that
module is there are other tools there's
quite a few tools that you can download
one of them that I like is object graph
object graph you can give it a Python
object and it'll actually graph the
references for that Python object so for
example if it's a data-driven
application you might be able to take
one of the pieces of data that's driving
the modalities in that program ask for
the pythons GC module actually be able
to tell you this object holds a
reference onto these objects and these
objects hold our reference for this
object so you take one of the one of the
data items that you have and you can see
who's holding a reference and you'll
begin to see some of the collection
structuring so in a financial example if
you're trying to figure out how a
portfolio analysis tool works you might
start with a single position and you'll
see from that well there's a portfolio
that holds a reference on to the
position there's some a larger object
larger object larger orbit in a GUI
program you might see some modal
dialogue is held by some windows held by
someone know some held by some window
and it'll give you an idea of the
structuring of the project because
remember at this 50,000 line of code
middle ground it's very possible that
the code is not well structured there
may be some structuring to the code base
but it may not actually reflect how the
code base works at 500,000 lines or five
million lines that starts to become
untenable because new people can't be
onward onto the project and figure out
where things are but at the 50,000 line
of code base it's very possible in your
mind to just remember where all the
interesting part is and it doesn't have
to be reflected in the code structure
the problem is all of these techniques
may then require further analyses and so
instead of actually looking at this
information itself one thing that I
always do is I always try and log it to
disk because you can generate megabytes
and megabytes and megabytes information
from the line profiler
because it's telling you every single
line that's run here I've you to
to Grandma which is a compression of
that information instead of generating
the histogram directly if you just log
every line and you have the ordering
there and you know that it's a
single-threaded application then you
might be able to do larger window
analysis remember the histogram is only
looking at one data item at a time
imagine once you have this on disks you
might say well what are what our bike
and think about it you could what are by
grams of function calls or lines that
are called
in some fashion so you can start to
apply some of the analysis techniques
that you're used to for the actual work
that you're doing to the code finding
which two function calls are likely to
appear you might even create a machine
learning model given this line of code
what's the most likely line of code to
follow it what would that tell you I
don't know but it might tell you
something kind of interesting and at
worst it'll be a really cool PI data
talk that'll help you find that next job
so one thing that I often used to try
when I was given these kind of code
bases is try to find the entry point I
am very much on the fence about how
useful it is to find the entry point of
an application it's useful in one
context if you have the time it's very
useful to find it because if you can
find the entry point of a Python
application as in wherever the main
function is or where the thing is
launched from it can very much help you
with some dynamic instrumentation
techniques where you need to inject or
wrap something and you need to make sure
that you're injecting or wrapping code
occurs first in the execution of the
program otherwise finding the entry
point and trying to trace the entry
point to the interesting parts of the
code base is a is you can start going
down rabbit holes and I've wasted so
much time going down that rabbit hole of
here's the main function here's what a
calls here's what it calls here's what
it calls oh now I need to know some
dynamic input to figure out where it
goes next and then the number of
possibilities those modalities explode
however if you have the if you have the
the entry point you might be able to do
some injection or wrapping that allow
you to find that allow you to inject
instrumentation to find the core
functionality so one of the other
questions I heard was how do we find the
functionality here who's impressed I'm
still holding on to the conceit that we
started 35 minutes ago get into a
debugger so because you have to analyze
this code dynamically yes you could emit
print statements or logging statement
and then subject those to put them into
a pan as data frame position so some
analysis but oftentimes that smart code
the code that you care about is small
enough that you just want to find it and
it's difficult to find it sometimes I've
I've signed myself up for like lightning
talks where I I promise to make this
change or that change the Python
interpreter without actually knowing
where that code is in the Python
interpreter Python interpreter is about
from memory about 150,000 lines of C and
Python code altogether so it's a fairly
large code base it's well designed and
it's well laid out but even then it's
difficult to find things for the talk I
did on Thursday one of the things I
wanted to find was where the Python
interpreter performed nfk
denormalization on tokens so i could
patch that out and I asked one of the
core developers who was there at the
conference and he didn't know off the
top of his head so I had to use
debugging techniques to try to find a
point which would allow me to trace
where in the interpreter the code is
that perform that action there's a
couple of things that you can do if
you're using Python 3.7 there's a new
breakpoint function that's been added in
Python 3.7 that will drop you into
debugger so if you can find some code
and you just type breakpoint as a
function you can actually drop yourself
into debugger wouldn't it be amazing if
the horrible code base you were given
happen to also be up-to-date with all of
the libraries and all the versions of
Python so maybe this is a little bit
speculative because there's a very good
chance of this terrible code base we're
talking about is written in Python 2.6
and if you use Python 2 point six point
two it breaks for some unknown reason
and it's using some version of
matplotlib that was only released on one
platform 15 years ago that's a
possibility there's a couple of other
tools that have been in Python for a
very long time the PDB module gives you
a debugger
there's post-mortem if you can find the
entry point one of the things you can
try doing is triggering the code to fail
rap-rap the entry point in a try except
once you get into the except after
you're triggered to fail maybe by doing
ctrl C to kill it to raise a keyboard or
if to kill it
the post-mortem will launch PDB into
something where you can go up and down
the back trace to figure out where you
killed it so run the application
so instrument the entry point or create
a new entry point that launches into the
original entry point instrument that
with try accept post-mortem find some
way to kill the applique
and then you get a back-trace that tells
you at least the the stack trace of
where you are and it might give you an
indication of where to look next in
order to find where some functionality
occurs
similarly PDP also has set trace so if
you have the ability if you kind of know
something adjacent to the interesting
part of the code just say from PDB
import set trace and call set trace but
PDB is a pretty weak tool sometimes what
I've done is in the code module in
Python in the standard library there's
something called interactive console you
can use interactive console to actually
drop your code into an interactive
console just like you typed Python in
the command line and it's about four
lines of code I've done this off enough
I can type these from memory and what
you can do is you find an interesting
part of the code base you drop into an
interactive console it's not as Rich's
PD because you can't go up and down the
stack trace to figure out where this was
called from you can't see that you can
use the inspect module to do some of
those things but this gives you an
interactive console so you can start to
do things like try to mutate the current
state instead of here this is taking a
copy of the Global's and locals but if
you just take the original locals you
can mutate that state and see what
happens
one of the techniques that I used to do
in C code all the time is instrument C
code with just something looks like this
interrupt three is trapped two debugger
so I'd run my C code under a debugger
trapped a debugger at that interesting
point and that would give me just enough
of a hook where I'm in the debugger at a
point which I kind of know something
about I can see the back trace and from
the back trace I can see where's the
next place where I'm gonna try and put
this debugger hook you can do the same
thing in Python using the signal module
and OS so if you add these three lines
you'll actually trap to a debugger the
problem is in a normal run of Python
this is just gonna cause the Python
program to seg fault
it'll just cord up for you so what you
need to do is you need to be running
Python under a debugger in order for
this to work however unfortunately these
techniques are kind of invasive and all
of these kind of presume that you have
the ability to take the code base and
change it imagine this code base is
deployed we have some production
deployment mechanism so you can't really
just deploy code into production that
has breakpoints all over the place and
so if you don't have the ability to
invasively change the code by adding
from PDB import set trace all over the
place or adding breakpoint statements
you're a little bit limited there are a
couple of techniques you can you can
approach that are similar to this
unfortunately one of the major
limitations is Python has no ability to
create what you might call a pure proxy
you can't take a data item in Python and
wrap it in something else either via
composition or inheritance to make it a
pure proxy one of the reasons for that
is if you have like a subclass of the
type of object that you have somebody
could have done type X is and you can't
fake that on the Python without going to
the sea level so in the absence of a
pure proxy the most you can do in Python
is subclass something implement those
underscore methods and try to capture
accesses like I did in the previous
slide with my OS not environ this is
just about the best you can do in Python
you can't just completely fake out an
object in order to catch where that
works I've had this happen before where
one piece of data and a large data
driven pipeline application was causing
the application to terminate I didn't
know which it was I tried to load all
the data that I knew the program was
going to use I wrapped them in proxy
objects and then I saw the moment one of
those proxy I've just had a method
called on it in order to figure out
where in the codebase the method was
being called that was causing an
exception in the code base like a
division error because my trace backs
were because this was embedded in a
runtime context where I couldn't see the
trace back and I couldn't get any
debugging information I need to do this
myself there are some significant limits
to what you can do with that but it's at
least a good start now
one thing that you could do none of this
code still works but a while back as a
joke I created a module called our watch
what our watch allows you to do is
allows you to put a hook on the Python
internal virtual machine every time a
variable is pushed to the Python
internal stack so every time pure Python
code is going to look at a variable you
can put a breakpoint it looks something
like this where you you can basically
tell Python every time you run a python
instruction that's going to look at a
variable give me a breakpoint
unfortunate this code is not maintained
but this is one approach where you can
actually start to try to get something
akin to a pure proxy and to debug these
situations where you have
where you have a data-driven
applications that just don't work or
where one piece of data is kind of
gumming up the works now one other thing
that you could do similar to the
debugging trick is you could in your
entry point register a trap Handler and
so you could tell Python when I get a
sig trap like when somebody sends that
kill signal to me I go into this handler
and that would allow you to have at
least one point where you could then use
the inspect module to get the current
frames and the outer frames and then
external to the program you just do kill
trap on the pit for the program what you
do in that case is inside that inside
that handler that you registered you'd
use the inspect module current frame and
get outer frames to figure out what the
back trace is or to figure what the
stack what track frames led you to that
point and you'll be able to get a little
bit information about where you are in
the program and what's going on one
thing that I've done is I've run pure
Python applications under gdb and then
just control C which are trap to my
debugger this can be helpful because
from the debugger I could put
breakpoints but I can only put
breakpoints on C code so this is only
really useful if I'm trying to debug
some Python application that is a Seikh
dimension or a C component to it and a
Python component and I'm trying to
figure out what's happening
on the boundary between both of those
but you could use this to maybe try to
find the entry point if in C you do a
break on them on main and figure out
where the main is implemented this is
one of the first things I did in Python
to figure out where the main function
for Python is implemented it's in Python
run dot C I believe no it's in the
programs directory under Python dot C no
I can't remember but what you could do
is you could use gdb to break on like PI
eval eval frame X and in the Python
standard in a source attribution of
Python there is a set of gdb macros on
our tools gdb Lib Python that allow you
to start to introspect from gdb the
Python layer so you can see from a gdb
sea level stack trace what are the
actual Python functions that call called
and that can start to give you some
information about what the frames were
evaluated and where you are this is a
very advanced technique that you would
only use if you had a Python application
that called him to see them and call it
the Python that's not that unusual
for data science code so I think one of
the last things that we might think is
how do we avoid inflicting this pain
upon others and I think that all of
these different techniques is grab-bag
of taking different techniques in this
general discussion kind of leads us to a
couple of takeaways in terms of how do
we avoid this problem make it easy to
run if you're writing code make it easy
for somebody to just run what that means
is create test code and make sure that
test code is up to date because that
test code is how they're going to
exercise the function out of your
program in order to get a hook into that
program to be able to find where things
are even if you don't document this is
the part of the module that's
interesting this is where the core is if
you can at least run it they can at
least start to use some of these dynamic
analysis techniques to try and figure
out where things are if not test code
give them sample code and make sure you
keep it up to date because that can also
help them exercise the modalities the
modules the functions that are used in
this code base and see how they enter
how they are structured and how they
interrelate with each other if it's a
data driven application please give them
two sample data because a lot of the
complexity and the functionality of that
application may be hidden in the data
that's used to drive the application if
you only provide them the code but you
don't provide them sample data they may
have no ability to really understand
what's going on make your code runnable
in the most isolated circumstances
possible ideally in some docker
container using some default version
like Ubuntu LTS with no network access
without access to a without access to
any shared folders so that they can
isolate what it is that this program
needs in order to run because in the
absence of that they're gonna find it
difficult to even get started with your
codebase to find a way to run the thing
because oh it needs this config file in
this directory it needs access to the
network in this place it it loads this
from the database much less before they
even try to figure out what modules I
have to install to get this thing to run
ideally make your code in portable as a
module I've seen many code bases were
the only way to actually get a runtime
context is to run the application by
calling it the command line if you're
gonna write your code make it importa
Balazs a module so somebody from inside
an interactive console can just import
your code
start to play around with small pieces
of it because when you when your code is
only runnable as a full program that
immediately requires that they start to
isolate the functionality of that down
to this function with this data produces
this results if you make it importa
Balazs a module then they can just start
importing pieces of the codebase and
immediately get down to they can whittle
down what they have to care about to
just one piece of your codebase we
talked about you know flat is better
than nested in the structuring of your
program you really want to have a fairly
flat structuring for your program or a
hub-and-spoke because otherwise when
they start to look at the stack frame so
the trace packs for that program they're
gonna find that the trace back where
some configuration parameter used is
here and then parallel to that there's
some trace back there's some some cut
out there's some code path that set the
environment where the variable and the
further up that is and the deeper that
is where the two of these code paths can
join the harder is for them to
understand so what you want is a very
flat code base where there's one
controller that calls a bunch of stuff
they can see in that controller oh load
this configuration get this user input
and then actually perform some operation
on that and ideally there's some
centralized hub where everything is run
from and you're not going down you know
50 frames deep before the code is
actually in its main loop where it's
trying to perform the core of the action
don't bother writing out documentation
like nobody's gonna do it like I could
tell you to write documentation don't
even bother
but asserts the assert name this the
assert statement in Python can be
alighted from running Python code if you
run Python with a - capital o a stirrup
statements get alighted from the ast in
fact if you use the debug variable at
200 scores before and after if you have
a line that says if debug that code
branch actually gets alighted it gets
removed as part of the parsing of your
Python code so instead of writing
assertions I start instead of writing
documentation at least put a couple of
assertions there so that somebody
reading through your code can say well
they said assert X is greater than 0
that's not going to be part of a runtime
check but at least at this point in this
point in this code I can assume that X
is greater than 0 because if they were
running this in a non optimized - oh
content
the thing would have failed and so you
can start to give people the ability to
constrain how many possibilities they
have to consider when they read through
your code by adding assert so at the
minimum if you're not going to write
documentation and don't bother because
nobody's gonna read it anyway
use asserts as a form of documentation
or use the if debug trick to put to put
into your code expectations that
somebody reading through it can use in
order to limit how much they have to
keep in their head when they're trying
to understand your code base and so
among all of those I hope you now have a
little bit more of a tool set for trying
to understand this problem this is a
very deep and complex problem any one of
these techniques would go into a great
depth I hope that was interesting to you
and I hope it gave you a couple of
techniques and some guidance and how to
maybe avoid inflicting this pain upon
your co-workers but you know what why do
you care you're leaving the company
anyway thank you so much
I think we're out of time for any real
questions did anyone have any real
questions hey who's actually had this
happen to you before really no bunch of
you have never been given some work
process that it wasn't documented wasn't
tested and now it's your responsibility
what do any any any techniques that you
used here that might be of relevance to
the rest of the audience
absolutely
and we can also see something about the
world which is some people like David
here are the kind of people who drive
down the street and I get every green
light and some of those of you who
raised your hands are the kind of people
to get every red light so you're always
the one who receives the code that David
wrote any other comments really that and
that and that's good because when I when
I leave places and they asked me to hand
over my work to somebody else I always
give them wrong documentation just to
stick it to them but if you videotape me
then you catch me with that but that's
if that's a vibrating Andy yeah
[Music]
that would be that would be amazing but
I think what happens to people leave
organizations is their email inbox just
disappears and so all the conversations
nobody records those conversations
nobody when I've been given these code
bases often times I've been told oh
here's a thread where people talked
about it and the thread has two comments
and three links and it's really
unfortunate so maybe maybe part of the
cases if you're building a code base
you're building something you have an
inbox where you can just see see
important relevant email threads for
later archiving because it's it's
absolutely case when you leave an
organization all your stuff gets
archived you know in case the SEC is
coming looking for it but nobody else
has ever ever has a chance to look is
anyone hiring
yeah that's a problem you're handing it
off you might generate reams of
documentation that the next person just
ignores because it's so often that it's
not useful at all okay I think we have
time for one more question or one more
comment yeah and the problem with Python
is sometimes you can't put the the
breakpoints assume that you have a
physical point but what if you're trying
to put a breakpoint on a code that's on
a function that's dynamically created
through some other process you can't put
a breakpoint in the IDE on that okay I
think that's all we have time for we
might have run a little bit over time
but thank you so much
[Applause]